Good morning Joan.
Did I just call you Joan?
That's different...
I wonder if this is gonna work.
If I go like this.
You never know what's gonna work with movie
magic.
The background didn't change but like the
- the inference from my facial position - you
don't know.
Usually it should be like this where I'm coming
over here and you're seeing that.
I moved my head and also the camera changed
position.
And you can see this is what this looks like
from this angle.
Surprise!
It's a computer and a window!
And a mess, a big terrible mess.
And then I'm like whaaat I'm back over here!
That's how it should work.
But I don't know if it works.
If I just do this?
I don't know.
We're going to find out when I'm editing the
video.
Alright, so there's a lot of stuff going on.
First - if you're American, and everybody
who is not American, this doesn't apply to
you.
But if you're an American you need to sign
up at the Health Care Exchange if you haven't
got insurance yet, 'cause the deadline is
like three days from now, and if you don't
sign up you will be fined because of how you're
a drain on society.
If you wanna know more about that there's
a link in the description.
Vidcon!
Less than three months away.
Freaking out!
This guy, right here.
Right now we're working constantly on content,
the stuff that when you go to Vidcon you do.
It's time consuming and terrifying, 'cause
I want you to have a good time.
So I spend a lot of time worrying about it.
When I say you, I mean people who can go to
Vidcon, I apologize to everybody who can't.
I'm - I really am sorry.
We've just launched three new channels.
Not - not just, but recently launched three
new channels.
How To Adult, with Mike and Emily: a guide
to how to graduate from adolescence without
completely crashing and burning.
Which isn't easy.
Two!
The Art Assignment, which actually happened
before How To Adult, but you've heard of The
Art Assignment!
It's a project with PBS and Sarah Green in
which WE ARE BRINGING CULTURE TO YOUTUBE!
If anybody ever tells you that Youtube is
a black hole of culture, show them The Art
Assignment.
Or you could just show them the rest of Youtube,
'cause it's - it's - it's pretty cool.
And three!
Launching on April first, and no, it's not
an April Fools Day joke: SCI SHOW SPAAAAAACE!
Was that good?
Space news, exploration, science, if it takes
place not on the planet of Earth we're covering
it.
What else?
Uh...
Cellphone camera time!
Nerdfighters here packing Project For Awesome
shirts.
Thank you guys!
Nerdfighters: "Hi!"
Volunteering.
We just switched over to a softer shirt style,
um this is an example of one.
They're just so much nicer to touch.
But that means that we have a bunch of old
shirts that we have to get rid of - so those
are back on sale at ten dollars.
When we moved warehouse, we had a huge sale.
We sold all of the ones that we thought we
were gonna sell, but now we wanna sell all
of them so that we can switch to the new shirts.
They are on sale for ten dollars.
There's a link in the description.
Say woo.
Nerdfighters: "Woo!"
AND I just finished my ALBUM!
It's on this, if you were wondering why I
hold up this hard drive while I say that.
Fourteen songs, some of them you've heard,
some of them you haven't, with my new band
Hank Green and The Perfect Strangers.
Yes, that is the name of my band.
I have a band, and it's called Hank Green
and The Perfect Strangers, and it is composed
of me, Andrew Huang, Rob Scallon and Joe DeGeorge.
And I have a BAND!
The album, barring unforeseen circumstances,
will come out at the end of April or beginning
of March.
No!
What comes after April?
May!
I wanna make an internet thing, and I'm pretty
sure this is how you do it, right, you just
say: "I want to make an internet thing!"
And then it becomes a thing!
So I love books, and I love receiving personal
recommendations for books to read.
Well, I wanna make a thing called Reviewsday
Tuesday, where every Tuesday you take a picture
of a book and then you review it on your instagram
or your tumblr or your twitter or wherever
you put pictures and words.
And all that needs to happen for this to be
a thing is for us to do it!
And of course, there are lots of other things
going on in my life right now, there's Crashcourse
Psychology and Crashcourse Literature and
Emma Approved and I'm trying to keep my colon
healthy and, you know, also maintain a village
of several hundred Banished villagers - this
is a video game I'm talking about right now.
I'm not saying it's a bad life, I'm just saying
I got a lot going on.
John, I am not comfortable with any outro
aside from I will see you on Tuesday.
So I will see you on Tuesday.
End screen, audio from The Art Assignment
episode:
Sarah: Hi!
Today we're outside the studio of the artist
David Brooks.
John: Are you trying to be as tall as me?
Sarah: I am as tall as you!
John: No, you are clearly not, you are cheating!